foreign
hello all
yes it's it's been a little while
um hang on I'm gonna adjust that just a
skosh
um I didn't do the uh the last what
would have been the previous scheduled
uh live stream because I was on vacation
it was good it wasn't relaxing it wasn't
that kind of a vacation
um but I'm back
I don't really have any planned uh
topics today we will talk about whatever
the hell we talk about
and all that
ah
so getting drunk no like I'm more of a
lightweight on hormones than I was back
when I thought I was CIS but I'm not
that much of a lie I'm not that cheap a
date
I mean not um
not in terms of getting drunk anyway it
might be a cheap date in otherwise
we'll leave that thought right where it
is
so yeah
um I put a video up in the break room
earlier the uh the secondary Channel
if uh if people uh aren't already
following that and kind of explained how
the uh the ongoing strike and my
intention to support it is going to
impact the channel here's the
short version
uh the short version is I am not going
to be reviewing anything that is a
recent release in theaters or an ongoing
um currently airing TV show which means
I'm not going to do a review of the last
episode of secret Invasion I'm not going
to talk about uh Star Trek's Chinese new
worlds
I won't be talking about Good Omens too
that this doesn't mean that I won't be
watching them but I won't be talking
about them because uh and this and this
isn't I explained this in the video this
isn't necessarily what all uh content
creators like me are going to do some
are finding their own ways of
um balancing you know trying to support
the unions and not
um inadvertently act as some sort of
promotion for the studios
my decision that I'm making is not to
review anything that is current I'll
still review some older stuff I'll still
do I'll still do classic Doctor Who I
will still
um wow actually ideally this will give
me the opportunity to try and catch up
on commissioned reviews yeah right
uh maybe that's a fun thought why don't
I like Fire and Ice I do like fire and
ice
but it's really bad like Fire and Ice is
a so bad it's good movie for me if
people aren't familiar with that one
that is a Ralph boxy
um rotoscoped uh R-rated uh fantasy
movie and
it's just it's just
so cheesy and so badly written and it
has the gayest villain to ever not be
confirmed to be gay it's not good but
damn is it fun
so it's not that I don't like Fire and
Ice it's just that I think it's bad like
not even like Ah that's my trash like I
say with stuff like I don't know um
what have I said that about I've repo
the Genetic Opera like I genuinely think
it's a bad movie
you get the right group of friends and
some drinks though it's a good time yeah
glad to hear the flood was nowhere near
your area yeah no I I wasn't in danger
with any of that thankfully have you had
any patreon requests for Sarah Jane
Adventure episodes no uh not
commissioned requests anyways I've kind
of addressed this elsewhere before I
don't have any intention of covering
Sarah Jane Adventures unless I get
commissioned to do it just because
I know a lot of people like it and I
know the reason a lot of people want me
to review it is because they want me to
like it too the thing is I watched about
the first season and a half and a couple
of sporadic episodes after that and it's
not bad but it's not for me it is aimed
at such a much younger demographic that
I just I know I'm not the audience and
I'm not going to talk about unless
somebody pays me because I don't like
going in feeling like I'm just gonna go
like it was okay I guess over stuff that
a bunch of other people deeply love and
I don't like to do that pay me for my
time if I'm gonna do that
shouldn't you be drinking Budweiser as a
trans woman
I know you have that marked as a joke
but
like beer is already terrible and you're
gonna oh even by beer standards and all
beer is bad
oh uh reminder while I will try and keep
up with the chat the only thing that
will guarantee interaction from me that
I answer your question or respond to
your comment is to do it as a super chat
which will also as a bonus
get you a little heart from me
and just be appreciated
hey there so I got back from hanging out
with my grandparents and my mom had fun
like I uh went to my first Wax Museum
and a 5D rail shooter oh that sounds
like fun Logan I haven't really been to
a proper wax museum where like
the Figures were the point I've been to
attractions where like Wax Figures were
part of it like I've been to the London
dungeon uh way back way way back on my
honeymoon
um but I've never like been to a wax
museum where the figures are the point
I'm sorry I know you're not a trans
woman I like I knew it was a joke anyway
so don't worry about it
Fringe reviews a lot of people it's like
is French having a Renaissance or
something is there a fringe saw no it
doesn't fit
um but like is is that show having like
a Resurgence of Interest lately or
something because like multiple people
brought up that show in the comments of
the video that I put up in the break
room so what is going on there
uh
forgive me for being a bit out of the
loop since you no longer use he do you
still go by the name Nathaniel I answer
to Nathaniel Nathaniel is not a dead
name it's not the one that I use most
commonly anymore I kind of Consolidated
everything under Vira just because
honestly it's freaking easier but like
I'm not offended if you call me
Nathaniel just don't refer to me by he
him pronouns and don't refer to me as a
man and we're all good
and I thought some people getting mad at
um Barbara because communism or
something I
no
like the exact people that you thought
were gonna throw a fit over the Barbie
movie are throwing a fit over the Barbie
movie and it's just
I
okay
uh
out of all the actors and actresses that
have played a companion and knew who
which one do you think would make a good
doctor
uh
Jenna Coleman would have made a good
doctor
I don't even like Clara as a companion
but she would have made a good doctor
um
shh
that's like the one that's leaping most
Forefront of my mind
I'm also like I'm trying to think back
to Classic now
yeah yeah I'm just gonna go with that
Jenna Coleman would have made a good
doctor
oh the thing with the map uh Parker like
that was a separate thing like
China's weird and finicky about a lot of
stuff so like that was a whole other
thing
I found all my Sonic screwdrivers in a
bag somewhere unfortunately the river
Sonic Screwdriver is very low on juice
oh oh no
ah
I'll take fun bad films over good film
anytime interesting you put a question
mark at the end of that channel very
uncertain about it saw barbie this
weekend A lot of people did
uh uh I didn't nor did I see Oppenheimer
I have too much crap going on and on in
my life
uh I get paid next week I'm interested
in joining your patreon which dollar
tiers get your name shout out on the
credits the shout outs start at
I believe 20.
the actual shout out sorry it's all laid
out on in the patreon itself the the
tier rewards will tell you where that
starts I believe it's 20 and up
pretty sure yes
uh how much time were uh was the trailer
reaction taking you considering you
won't be doing them for the foreseeable
I mean yeah trailer reaction is the
other thing I'm not going to be doing uh
that one definitely not going to be
doing I'm
uh the thing is like
not talking about current like honestly
the break room stuff doesn't free up all
all that much of my schedule because the
break room is it's low effort by Design
that's why it's a secondary channel so
you know the and the uh trailer
reactions especially are very low effort
on my part I barely have to even gather
my thoughts to do those
but I mean it's just it's just gonna be
filled with other stuff oh and some
people like Express concerned about a
hit to my finances like you you folks
need to realize I do not make very much
off the break room the break room exists
because there's a lot of stuff I want to
talk about that if I were to try and put
it all on the main Channel it would drag
it down in the algorithm because a lot
of it wouldn't perform well that's why
the break room exists the break room
while it does make some money is not
it's not something I'm dependent on
um
like I make more on uh the on the spicy
site than I do on uh on the break room
by a factor of like four or five so uh
it's not that big of a hit to my
finances I'm still going to be putting
stuff out there anyway I'll be fine
let's see
stall those hearts from Jessie I stole
nothing
Terrace dollar thank you very
Chad hi Vera I tried to find a place to
stream a repo but couldn't find it do
you know where I can find it
um hmm see I own it on DVD
so
streaming
it looks like oh it's on Amazon Prime
from the look of it
checking that
yeah it's uh it's on Amazon it's well
it's on freebie which you can view on
Amazon Prime so like it's gonna play
with ads
um but it is so it's like it's on 2B
it's on Pluto it's on VUDU it's on
Amazon Prime freebie um and all of these
are gonna run it with ads but it's it's
it's a number of places it's out there
teaching
weird question have you seen the
the what
this DVD toilets
yes that is a very weird question I do
not understand it
uh would you ever go more in depth on
why you think it's bad I genuinely liked
it I it's a incredibly generic story
with a very weird progression odd
um
odd divergences wooden performances
like I'd have to re-watch it to go into
more detail than that it's
it's just a generically bad movie to to
me to my taste I've seen it crop up on
like some people's like underappreciated
gems list and I'm like
I mean you do you but if I was gonna
pick a Ralph boxy it it wouldn't be that
one
I go American pop before I would go
Fire and Ice and I'd go Wizards before I
go American pop so
you know
so I'm guessing you're not going to
cover the new Superman Animated Series
where Lois apparently looks like the
main character from our house uh no I
will not be covering that at least uh
not
um as it is airing I may or may not
cycle back around to do videos on some
of these things once the strike breaks
up but depending on how long the uh the
strike lasts uh who knows
although I don't I myself don't drink
any alcohol I feel actually obligated as
a German to defend beer on principle
hence how dare you insult beer like that
see I really appreciate living in
Vermont because we
we are not like exclusive in our love of
hard cider but there's a lot of cideries
around here like there's a lot of
breweries as well but I don't need to go
to a brewery I can go to a cidery I can
go to Woodchuck I can go to Stow cider I
can go to Citizen cider it's all so good
it's good meat around here too actually
recently I was worried you'd be mad at
me because I'm odd for someone who Jesse
blocked on Twitter I explained that to
my emotional counselor and realized it
was paranoid yes
that's definitely a paranoia uh because
this is literally the first time hearing
about it and like having not heard about
it I do I don't care
like you need to realize uh
uh I can't speak for Jesse's uh specific
mentality when it comes to who she does
or doesn't block I can tell you what my
mentality is my mentality is I don't
want that energy in my feed
I would say like
maybe one percent of the people I've
blocked on either Twitter sorry X
account
it's a stupidest damn thing
um only about one percent have ever done
something that actually personally
offended me directly like came at me or
tried to attack me and the rest is just
like I don't want that energy in my feed
I just block them and if you were to
come back at me later and Go why'd you
block this person I go I don't freaking
know
again that's me I can't speak for Jesse
I love your reaction when I told you
that Wicked was going to be made into
two parts that's such a stupid idea
that's a terrible idea I
ah
God I can't believe they're doing this
such a bad idea
speaking of repo where does Devil's
Carnival land on the bad Spectrum fun
bad bad bad I haven't seen that one so I
couldn't tell you
uh question have you ever heard of the
series agent Elvis with Matthew
McConaughey as Elvis and his executive
produced by Elvis's wife uh ex-wife
Priscilla Presley who also voices
herself I haven't
anime where it exists I don't think I've
even watched a trailer
any new thoughts on David returning his
14th doctor I'm not gonna have new
thoughts until I see the specials and I
have full context of what story they're
doing with this I'd like I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna have new thoughts for a
while
uh I know you're not the biggest fan of
Torchwood I'm not but which three
episodes stand out to you the most don't
include children of Earth because that's
cheating ah
um
the season opener for series two was
really good I really liked that one a
lot
um
Countryside I really liked that was
where I felt like series one was
starting to turn it around
um
and
I don't know
it's it's all bled together at this
point
screw it cyber woman why not let's have
some absurdity while we're at it
you didn't necessarily say which I
thought were the three best you said
which three stand out the most cyber
woman does indeed stand out
so there you go
have I seen any other Greta girl week
films I have seen her version of Little
Women and I adore it it is wonderful
uh see
Elijah Anderson thank you
very much
for the uh
uh for the Super Chat sorry like I I
don't all right I'm going to ask for
forgiveness if this by coincidence
happens to be a misgendering but I
cannot stop myself from just going Mr
Anderson
apologies
oh love your videos about the Hollywood
strike morbidly curious about the
Fallout in the coming years I'm looking
to watch some of the DC anime Universe
movies any you recommend much love from
Boise yeah it will I will be I'm very
hopeful for the for the unions that are
striking
um
uh not related to Hollywood but the the
UPS the teamsters just got uh basically
the uh the deal that they wanted more or
less uh from UPS right before they were
about to strike so I'm really happy for
that I feel like
I mean granted they're very different
lines of business but I feel like
what the actors and the writers are
doing and how long they appear to be
prepared to go uh for this I think a lot
of other companies I think it is
emboldening unions in general because
they're seeing unions be strong which we
haven't really seen on a large scale in
a while in this country
and I think that emboldens them and
makes uh makes corporations more nervous
which is good
uh that there's a pub here that carries
a lovely pear cider from Vermont yeah a
lot of the a lot of cideries have a pair
variant somewhere in there
um oh uh so yeah the dcau movie so okay
it depends on whether you are asking me
about like
uh the Tim verse the the stuff that uh
all kind of falls under Bruce Tim and
was like connected to the Batman
animated series The completely
Standalone things or the uh sort of
integrated Universe they tried to do
that was largely based on the new 52 the
one that started with Justice League War
because if you're asking me for
recommendations on that last one uh I
don't have a lot I ended up ultimately
bailing on that because a lot of it is
really really
painfully
bad and a lot of it centers on Batman
and Damien should die
so
um but in terms of stuff that came out
that was in that Universe Batman bad
blood wasn't too bad largely because it
was the one where characters actually
told Damien to shut the hell up so that
helped
um that one wasn't too bad uh justice
league dark was pretty good
um
Gods and Monsters was good but that
wasn't technically part of that
continuity
uh God I'm trying to think what else
most of it was most of it was really bad
like really bad
the Aquaman one was bad the Justice
League ones were bad the Batman ones
were really bad
it was bad it was uh not good
not good
X gonna give it to you uh
you wanna know something I realized a
while ago in 15 years Superman will be a
century old which is insane to me it's
not insane to me because like
Superman is so old that like it just
gets lumped into
stuff that was new when my grandparents
were young
so like
coming up on 100 years that kind of
feels about right
what are my thoughts on famous movies of
the 80s 90s and early 2000s being
adapted into Broadway musicals uh on in
uh uncreative
boring it's because it's become the
standard go-to and I'm really done with
it and I know why they do it because
these things make a hell of a lot more
money
than completely original stuff
so
ah
it just becomes a safer investment on
the part of
producers and theaters to put that stuff
up and so they keep making it
I have no interest
like
I don't think I really have much
interest in any of it I think I was like
mildly morbidly curious about
uh Legally Blonde the musical back when
that was new
um but like when it started pouring in
and it was
Heather's and it was Mean Girls and it's
it's all this stuff and I'm like I I
don't
care
I don't care
uh have you seen the trailer of adult
swims
uh Uzumaki I would highly recommend the
manga many have called him the Japanese
Lovecraft yeah I'm familiar with junji
Ito I do not intend to read him unless
somebody pays me to do it
um because
um what I've seen of his work is the
kind of stuff that I don't want swimming
in my head
uh uh unless I'm being compensated for
it if that makes sense and I don't mean
I think it's bad I mean
so like as a comparison
um and also you know Lovecraft was a
massive racist and actually not that
good a writer
um so I'm not even sure it's a
flattering comparison
um he he does dabble in the sort of
cosmic end of horror I'll give you that
much but anyways uh while this has
nothing to do with the specific type of
horror that Uzumaki does I think the
scariest movie uh ever made is the 1970s
version of Invasion of the Body
Snatchers and I love it to death and I
also rarely and I mean rarely watch it
because I can't watch it and have a good
night's sleep afterwards if I watch that
movie I will have a bad night's sleep
and I will have unsettling dreams
every time without fail and junji ito's
stuff
it gives me that same feeling in my gut
like this is just gonna be a bad night
this is just gonna be a bad night so I
don't really intend to dip too much into
his stuff that trailer is there a new
trailer I know there was one a while ago
but then like it was being delayed I
don't know what happened
do I like Jack Daniels not especially
something random on my mind lately why
is Nightmare on Elm Street 2 widely
considered a positive queer movie well
it's basically considered a positive
queer movie because it's considered a
queer movie at all you need to remember
that thing was made in the 80s
deliberately making a queer movie that
wasn't about that wasn't directly about
how horrible it is to be queer
um that's a big deal so while it's not a
positive queer movie by most standards
we would have now in terms of positive
depictions you know celebration Pride
etc etc etc it is a undeniably queer
flavored movie where the queerness
itself is never condemned
so that's why because you have to
realize that was the bar in the freaking
80s
[Music]
anyone remember when they did that under
the Red Hood fault that was essentially
bandersnatch
um
no I don't know what you're talking
about under the Red Hood wasn't very
good either and that one I get into
fights with people over because like oh
the animated version that's so good it's
like it's not though
it's not terrible but it's not that good
uh
let's see
oh hey Megan good to see you you snuck
in
hope you're doing well
uh let's see where are we did you see
the Lovecraft country series they tried
to push I did uh I covered it on the
break room when it was airing I it was a
very uneven C uh series when it was good
it was great
and sometimes it was great
but it it wasn't always great it wasn't
even great the majority of the time
at least not to my taste I got I got
some bitter arguments uh with me for my
position on that and I don't want to I
don't really feel like revisiting and
delving into that but yeah I that that
series did not fully click with me with
the exception of a couple of that
basically three episodes there's three
episodes that I think are absolutely
fantastic and the rest of it I have
varying issues with or just didn't land
right with me
do I like slasher movies nope no I do
not
uh you think it feels weird in modern
adaptations of superheroes that it's set
in a world where superheroes don't
already exist it's so different from
uh our world at this point I think
um so do you mean set in a world where
superheroes don't exist in fiction
[Music]
I mean no I don't think it's that weird
it's kind of like how in most zombie
movies despite the fact that in reality
everyone knows what a zombie is the
reaction to zombies and most zombie
movies is what's going on I don't
understand and nobody has a point of
reference
for like don't you know what a zombie
movie is oh hey Jessie good to see ya
thoughts on Godzilla in general King
that's it that's that's the thought
that's what you're getting
[Laughter]
uh Jesse you are pulling attention away
from me how dare you how dare you
I'm more than all tired of superheroes
at this point I'm not tired of
superheroes I am kind of over the
interconnected Universe like I feel like
the the benefit of the interconnected
universe that is the MCU has given the
best it's going to give and I kind of
want things to be treated mostly
independent at this point
do you like DC's Robin AKA Damian do you
dislike DC's Robin AKA Damon Wayne
because Stephanie Brown did a better job
as Batman's partner no I dislike Damian
Wayne because he's a little [__]
I don't it's not a comparison I don't
like him on his own merits
he's a turd he's a terrible now again
bear in mind
I know him mostly from the animated
films in which he appeared not so much
as comic book stuff I heard that under
certain writers he was good or that he's
gotten better since blah blah blah blah
but from what I've seen of Damien I find
him insufferable he is absolutely awful
and I hope he dies
and that has nothing to do with
Stephanie Brown
would you rather be tied to a chair
gagged and forced dwarfs shining or
Moulin Rouge well okay first of all drop
the movies don't threaten me with a good
time
um I don't know which one's shorter
uh by the way I got a recording of that
short play wrote and uploaded it now oh
that's cool very nice
sorry I'm in between meetings yeah isn't
that your life now
the Jesse gender life story in between
meetings
[Laughter]
uh what idea have you always wanted
Doctor Who to explore but they never did
I really want them to do a lot more with
the concept of a dialect Civil War it
was something that was basically going
on in the background
um across the ladder or half of the
classic era and the modern era has only
ever touched on in the tiniest ways like
with
um like little hints of stuff with the
new paradigm dialects or the
um
or the reconnaissance style likes
created in Revolution of the dogs and
the Clones of that like they'll touch on
it briefly like I really want the show
to properly delve into that I'm sure
some people will say like big finish has
done it I'm sure they have big finishes
touched all of it
am I aware of the backstory of
Godzilla's creation well you mean the
fact that he was
inspired by the destruction of the
nuclear bomb and basically was created
because the Japanese weren't allowed to
make
um actual Cinema about the literal
freaking bomb yeah I know that
do you have a favorite Mission
Impossible film I think Philip Seymour
Hoffman might make mi3 my favorite just
by default he is he is easily the best
villain that the mission of all
impossible franchise ever had and he
boosts that one up a lot uh no the one I
like best is the
fifth one Rogue Nation I like Rogue
Nation a lot
have I ever seen live action Inspector
Gadget films I saw the first one I was
working at a movie theater when that was
out
I don't want to talk about it
don't you get annoyed when Dr with
Doctor Who reheating idea more and more
and Shine from new more Innovative
Concepts
it depends on the nature of it like I
don't have a problem with the show as
old as Doctor Who revisiting certain
ideas
um as long as it has a self-awareness as
long as it's not treating reheated ideas
like they're like they're new and
exciting like oh are we clever like no
you're doing the thing again but like
sometimes the show seems very aware that
it's it's just doing the thing again and
I could be okay with that as long as it
doesn't
um become all that it does and I don't
think it is
Moulin Rouge two hours seven minutes
shining is two hours 26 minutes okay
Moulin Rouge by default
who do you prefer in terms of
Spider-Man's kids Annie May Parker or
Mayday Parker the thing is I have not
read the comics in which either of those
characters appear
um
excuse me
so I cannot give you an answer uh on
that
is mission impossible to the one for the
Mission Impossible hipsters I think
mission impossible to anyone who says
that's their favorite they're just a
contrarian or like they just it's just
not a franchise they were ever gonna
like and they like the one that is least
like
literally every other entry in it
I don't even think that's a hipster
thing that's literally just a oh so
you're just not the audience for this so
you liked the one that didn't fit
for all the crap that's going on in
bread tube in such a little sanity and
edutainment is nice to have right now
I don't even want to know what that's in
reference to Dharma
like I mean that sincerely don't tell me
I really don't want to know
uh
how are you going with strangling worlds
do you feel the season two has been a
step up or down from the first one well
yum yum podcast I am not uh doing review
content while the strike is going on for
currently airing products so I shall uh
politely refrain uh from answering that
what I will say because I already did a
review on this the second episode of the
second season is the best episode of the
show thus far I don't have a fully
formed opinion on the season as a whole
and if I did I wouldn't say at this
point
what's a film you think was ahead of its
time uh
that's a good question but it's the kind
of question I can't come up with an
answer off the top of my head
so I'm gonna have to pass and it's a
shame because that's a that's a
legitimately good question
if Doctor Who ever rebooted things
completely it shouldn't uh would you say
it would ruin things or would fans react
to it similarly to the new regeneration
like with the ninth doctor came in no it
would absolutely ruin it never reboot
Doctor Who I did a whole video on that
never ever ever ever ever ever never
reboot Doctor Who don't you dare don't
you freaking dare
I thought you hated The Shining you
changed your mind no no I didn't I I
no I'm not sure what I said they gave
you that impression
that I changed my mind that's a terrible
movie it sucks
and I'm gonna say it now because the
question is going to come up again no
it's not because I think it was a bad
adaptation of the book I've never read
the book I just think the movie sucks
on its own merits
much like I think Damian Wayne sucks on
his own merits I don't need it to be in
comparison to another thing that's good
to think the thing sucks
uh although that does sometimes happen
sometimes I wonder why do some of the
worst people make some of the best stuff
you know the people who I'm talking
about
because
Talent has no correlation to humanity
I mean it doesn't and I don't mean in
that all the best stuff is made by
[__] it's not there is good people
making good stuff but like
you take a quality piece of work and how
good the person was who made it has no
bearing on it whatsoever
I think the quality of the mission
impossible films depends on the length
of Tom Cruise's hair I've seen that
theory
do I like the song Barbie Girl of course
I don't nobody likes it it's annoying as
hell
I do mean that sincerely like there is
an ironic enjoyment of it but I was
there when it was quote-unquote quote
unquote popular I don't know anyone who
enjoyed it sincerely
our philosophy is
thank you kindly
the greatest fear of anti-work channels
is that RTD2 will be good they're not
afraid of that they'll just claim it's
bad
that's like
if we're talking Doctor Who specifically
they arguably benefited from the chibnol
era not being especially well written
and they could blame that on wokeness
but like it's not like they're suddenly
gonna change their tune if everybody
loves what Russell T Davis is doing
they won't they'll still claim it's bad
they'll they'll still zero and you
actually you know what will happen is
they will stop talking about the quality
of it and they'll just focus in on the
woke stuff
so talking about chibnol they harped on
you know ah they're it's bad because
it's woke when we get to RTD2 assuming
that it's good it might be it might not
be we don't know but let's assume for
the moment that it is if that is good
what they will do is simply not even
talk about is it good is it bad they'll
just zero in on well this is woke and
they're pushing this and that's bad like
the thing that they're pushing is bad
okay but do you think the show's any
good woke I thought just shift Focus I
don't think I don't think they're afraid
at all I think they have a Playbook
they're gonna stick to it
I had so much fun the last time I
watched Mission Impossible 2 I totally
wouldn't call it my favorite but I
probably say it's not the worst my
controversial Mission Impossible pain is
that I don't like Fallout I don't really
like Fallout either
I think fallout's probably my
second least favorite
well uh see here's my controversial
opinion I don't think Ghost Protocol is
very good
I think that here's the thing
I think the really good ones it's
actually it's been the inverse of the
Star Trek thing it's been the odd
numbered ones for me I like the first
one I like the third one I like the
fifth one I haven't seen the seventh one
um but I I up until this point I've
enjoyed the uh the odd number ones the
even ones haven't really done it for me
I didn't like two I think it's just kind
of a mess I don't think those protocol
is very good everyone else loves it I'm
like it's not great
um
and Fallout didn't do a lot for me
the Dalek in Dalek do you think it was a
sympathetic character mildly about as
sympathetic as you should ever make a
Dalek
favorite YouTube series I mean probably
Zero Punctuation still that's just
comfort food for me
do you have a favorite character that's
just a downturner or schmuck Arthur Dent
that would be me there I love it
unironically
love you for that Carolyn
questions have you seen the super Sun's
animated movie
so if you don't like The Shining I
gather you I've never watched doctor
sleep the sequel I actually have been
meaning to I've heard really good stuff
about it and I'm curious to watch it but
no I have never gotten around to that
RT our
td2 or R2D2 yes Miss Wicked Wolf yes
we're aware of the similar similarity
uh
Ollie wants his face is already
screaming about the world because well
people stop responding to him
like ignore him
here's the thing some of these people
should not be ignored and should be
responded to because their ideas are
legitimately dangerous that is
unfortunately where people like Matt
Walsh and Ben Shapiro fall into their
ideas are legitimately dangerous and
they shouldn't be ignored and they
should be pushed back and they should be
discussed debunked and responded to
Ali London is it like
I'm gonna swear so apologies [__]
ignore him
I mean it
I really mean it
don't talk about him don't don't reply
to him don't retweet him don't snapshot
and comment just ignore him
hi
going back to your critical lens video
do you feel that you're getting more
comments explained to the plot now that
you are Femme presenting
um
that's really hard for me to judge
because the channel also got bigger
after I became Femme presenting so
I mean by raw number
maybe but I'm not gonna draw a
correlation there because my audience
was also getting bigger at the same time
as I started presenting feminine at all
and and as I continue to do it more and
more so
I I don't think those are connected
um in terms of causation there might be
a correlation but I think that is more
to do with the time at which my channel
got bigger
putting aside the recasting the fact
that a forthcoming big finish release
has an image of Harry Sullivan on the
cover aged up to look older than Ian
Mater ever got to is Icky yeah
yeah I'm not I really am not a huge fan
and like to be fair I haven't listened
to them like maybe they're really good
um but I I have I
sexually I don't like bringing in the
sound of likes
for on big finish releases I'm like I've
even told
um their uh managing director
um Jason hey Gallery I I literally told
him that to his face
[Laughter]
um like I I don't think they're like
necessarily wrong to do it but like it
just doesn't sit right with me
personally I don't love it
okay
um
nine months Sub-Zero regret infinite Joy
thank you Dharma I appreciate that
Supremo Mega
question on the Bronze Age 1970 to
1986. do you feel that is when
mainstream superheroes comiced comics in
the big two Pete that's when deaths and
Lasting changes still mattered
probably
yeah
um because that was you know when they
were
um DC especially was doing some really
interesting things with character deaths
and they had Legacy characters and
the bringing back of iconic versions of
characters and
dethroning removing or sometimes even
erasing from Canon Legacy characters to
me will go down as the greatest creative
mistake DC ever made
um so yeah actually I do think it's
probably a fair assessment now that's
not necessarily going to mean that I
think all that stuff is great or I'm
gonna find my favorite stuff in that era
but like collectively in terms of where
the storytelling was going and what it
was doing for the industry as a whole
when talking about the big two being
Marvel in DC yeah yeah that was probably
when they were creatively at their
strongest and most proper and most
promising
what's my go-to comfort food
uh
whatever I can make in 10 minutes or
less
do I like coco or Encanto more I don't
know because I only saw Coco the one
time
I'm inclined to say in Kanto but as I
said to be fair I haven't re-watched
Coco
who's Ollie that is the correct question
and you do not need an answer
did you
Discord yes okay so I need to pop on to
the Discord really quick reminder
Council geek's Discord is a patreon
exclusive perk and that is another place
where you can ask me questions that I uh
will absolutely answer so let me see
what I've got there have you seen the
new trailer for Wonka I did I
and I kind of shrugged
if you have seen the new trailer for a
Wonka based on what you've seen of his
performance what do you think about
Timothy chalamus Wonka well it seems
very clear he's doing a younger version
of
um
oh my God
Gene Wilder huh Gene Wilder zwanka which
like cool
okay
it was never published but there was
almost a Star Wars extended Universe
novel that explained why there are
humans in another galaxy a long time ago
basically it was going to be a group of
humans fleeing Earth because a dystopian
regime that suppressed emotion and
individuality was taken over the planet
implied to be the regime from uh THX
1138 but their ship hit some kind of
temporal anomaly like you do uh and get
transported to another galaxy two
billion years in the past you think
there's any real need to explain the
presence of humans and Star Wars we all
know it's just because it's a space
fairy tale so we need the protagonist to
be human or close to human no I don't
think there's any need
um but like if you're going to explain
it doing it in a side thing like a novel
or comic because like there are some
fans who don't think like I do and don't
appreach approach media like I do who do
want to know that there is an answer
like I don't have a problem with an
answer existing I sure as hell don't
care and I don't think it's necessary
but I also understand that my
perspective and the way that I approach
media is not the only one out there and
it's not the only one that's valid like
the only part of that that I think is
clever is the connection to THX
1138 other than that I'm like this is
deeply unnecessary
uh
to what
uh extent if at all can you enjoy
stories where the characters are
interesting but not really in any way
moral I noticed that's an issue you have
with the house of the dragon and I feel
that's a lot of classic literature you
can enjoy if it's uh hand up for you
like a lot of Shakespeare plays have no
real good guys
that's not really true a lot of
Shakespeare plays the protagonist is not
a hero
but there's still somebody there to
relate to like you can take something
like Hamlet because Hamlet himself is a
[__]
he is not a good person at all and he's
the hero of the story or you can take
something like Julius Caesar where there
is a reason that these people are going
to kill him and it's not a completely
invalid one so he's not a great person
they're not great people but the thing
is a lot of it has to do with
whether or not the only I think it has
less to do with whether or not they're
moral as it does at least for me whether
or not the only thing motivating
everybody is self-interest
because when everybody is motivated by
nothing other than their own
self-interest with nobody having any
other priorities any other moral
guidelines anything else that they care
about
I'm bored
and it just makes everything very flat
and I won't say House of the Dragon
totally fell into that but it like it
came close
at a few points and it helps me to know
especially with something like House of
the Dragon like you're kind of
extrapolating out my specific issues
with House of the dragon and assuming a
grander thing which I don't think tracks
the thing with House of the dragon is
um you're trying to get me to care about
who ends up on the throne and I don't
like any of these people and most of the
world that you're showing me isn't a
world worth saving so they're fighting
over a world I don't think seems that uh
interesting and I don't and I'm not
invested in whether or not any of them
succeed because they don't seem like
decent people
so that has more to do with the
culmination of very specific
these people are all deeply selfish
there isn't a lot of nuance going on
here the world itself doesn't seem like
it's that like it's worth saving or I
should really care who controls it it
like it's a combination of all those
things it was strong enough written in
the in the characterization and the
performances that I did get through it
and assuming the strike's not still
going on I will come back to it but that
one had specific problems
when Anna kasparian got called out uh on
her uh got called out Biola Progressive
oh God
I might decline to answer this depending
on where this question is going
and colleagues initially tried to
patiently explain to her why what she
was saying was problematic they only
started telling her to go to hell when
she rebuked them multiple times why does
that part always get memory hold when
people tell the story of how they got
canceled
because it makes them the victim
like why would you talk about how people
tried to have a reasonable conversation
with you and you refuse to listen that
doesn't fit the narrative you want to
exist
uh
like do you think Anna's just lying or
do you think her uh recollection of
events changing newly is I said one
thing and everyone instantly turned on
me I have no idea what she what she does
or doesn't think I have no idea what she
does or doesn't remember what I think is
that human beings for a lot of people
will defensively
remember things in a way that favors
them most and not even consciously in
most points
like if you if you get in your own
perspective enough so like let me step
out of politics for in for a moment and
give you an example
I feel like it is not a super uncommon
thing for two people who are in a
relationship
and one of them has had something that
is bothering them it may or may not be
something about the other person it may
not even have anything to do with the
relationship but there is something in
their life that is bothering them and
they don't want to burden
their partner with it and so they hold
on to it and it just makes them
irritable
until it gets to a point where they
can't handle it anymore and they blow up
or if it is something relating to the
relationship they suddenly go hey we
need to talk about what's going on in
our relationship and from the
perspective of the other person
their partner just blew up out of them
blew up at them out of nowhere but from
the perspective of the person who just
got upset they've been sitting with this
so long that from their perspective they
can't take it anymore
now either perspective is completely
within their own heads
so that's the natural thing the
perspective you have and if you're the
one who has gotten angry the fact that
the other person doesn't understand can
make it even more frustrating for you
and if you're the one whose partner just
got really angry you can find yourself
just deeply confused and you can find
yourself getting upset because they
won't they won't explain to you what the
hell is even going on
so like people
people very naturally frame things in a
way that
conforms to their perspective and their
perspective is insular most of the time
and that's just gonna result in you have
to go out of your way to consider other
people's perspective it's work to
consider other people's perspective
and when you don't do it this is what
happens
favorite summertime beverage adulter
otherwise
what is better skirts or shorts skirts
which is better Blood Stained or Rogue
Legacy 2 as a metroidvania as a
metroidvania Blood Stained is better
in terms of addictiveness Rogue Legacy 2
has it beat but because Rogue Legacy 2
is
um procedurally generated it doesn't
have the carefully orchestrated layout
of like a proper metroidvania it's
metroidvania-esque but procedural uh
generation means it won't be as
meticulously put together it's something
like Blood Stained
what is your stance on wearing felt hats
during summer I wear one and get
constant looks people wondering how I
can sand the heat but a good felt cowboy
hat is actually quite cool and even
deflects a lot of the Sun from you
I don't have a stance because I have
literally never considered the
implications
of a felt hat
particularly a felt cowboy hat in the
summer
yeah caught me off guard with that one
with Scientists working on
nuclear-powered Rockets which will in
effect cut down travel to Mars from
months to weeks if we manage to have a
functional Martian Colony within the
next 20 years would you go no
no I wouldn't go for the same reason I
wouldn't go on a trip to the bottom of
the ocean and I wouldn't move to the
desert like
power to anyone who's going to do that
no I no
with Marvel debuting a new Punisher oh I
freaking forgot
Black Ops soldier named Joe Garrison
with the skull design being very
downplayed though still present do you
think the Punisher is still a relevant
character in and of itself personally I
think the Punisher is always going to be
relevant as long as they're going they
are gaping holes in the criminal justice
system with the stories allowing for
some form of cut flowers says I
there are good Punisher stories out
there by and large The Punisher for me
is at his most digestible when he is
treated with a certain degree of camp
and a certain degree of acknowledgment
that he is not okay
I look at the Punisher stuff that was
being made in the late 80s into the 90s
and frankly it makes me sick
I have a very low tolerance at this
point for visual anti-characters like
him
where the Assumption as well these
people slipped through the through the
holes of the criminal justice system and
I'm gonna clean it up like
the more that I've learned about the
justice system and learned who actually
slips through the cracks
the fact that people who actually slip
through are bankers
and Executives and CEOs whose decisions
leave millions of people homeless
starving dead
and they get paid a fine that is a
fraction of the money they earned by the
decisions that they made
and even when they break the law they
never go to jail
give me a story where the Punisher
starts hunting down the one percent and
maybe I'll start paying attention to
them start paying attention to them
again until then honestly retire the
character
retire the character
the police are militarized enough so the
idea that we need a gun-toting lunatic
on the street because the police aren't
Tough Enough
[__] off
no
foreign
the visceral thrill that can come with
it when it's done well and like I said
when it's when when the Punisher is done
well is with a certain degree of camp
and of unrealistic situations I think
it's why he tends to work very well when
you put him against the mob because it's
already a
um
fantasized
uh version of organized crime like the
organized crime has never actually been
like this so throwing him at that I'm
okay with that's why I'm okay with
stories like uh welcome back Frank
that's why I like Punisher war zone
because
it's him taking on a fantasy version of
a problem and it's a problem that to
whatever degree the mafia is even still
going concern they're not the ones that
are being ground down
um by the police but when I think back
to the early 90s when Frank was driving
around in a van
ing down anyone compliciting gang
violence
no we don't need that we didn't need it
then and we sure as hell don't need it
now
so there's that opinion for you
foreign
I'm gonna try and catch up on the
um
on the chat real quick and then I'm
gonna wrap it up personally more
interested in the center Sony Marvel
movies like Venom AKA Sony's not
Spider-Man because it leaves those
movies try different things although
whether they stick The Landing yeah a
lot of them don't but I have had fun
with the Venom movies
uh in particular I I won't lie
um
with the success of the Mario Brothers
movie and Barbie and the smaller year in
films overall is there a danger
Hollywood will go further down the
established properties only Trend after
the strikes the major Studios might
doesn't mean all of the industry will
suprimo Mega
thank you for the Super Chat on death do
you feel Gene should have stayed dead I
know she's the Phoenix but I feel
Reviving her cheap in the uh emotional
power of dark Phoenix Saga honestly I
don't know cause I haven't read the
actual story where she came back
um I've only kind of read descriptions
about it so I can't really have an
opinion on that
uh conceptually I don't have a problem
with it even though in general I don't
like bringing back characters because
again you know
yeah Phoenix
I I still get what you say but like I I
guess I don't have that strong an
opinion
uh thoughts on The Flash movie have not
seen it don't plan to
uh
dude
technically Wilson Fisk is the the one
percent the Kingpin himself is kind of
an odd thing to
to deal with he's still he's still coded
as a gangster more than a
um
actual one percenter
another great live stream from another
YouTuber I followed just started guess
I'm off and away see you next time
thanks for stopping in Kura
well it won't exactly be Punisher or
more like the chromy Zorro made me I'll
think of something
okay
uh I really like the tick tock video
where the kid thought you were Wonder
Woman yeah that was sweet
we cool I'm not in a good place right
now I've been experiencing really bad
anxiety lately uh we cool 255 A.D I'm
not upset
you have not offended me
it's all good
it's okay I promise
do you think Judy Whitaker should have
gotten another season but without Chris
chippendal to prove she was shortchanged
by the writing I mean I would have liked
to have seen that but if she was done
with the part she wasn't obligated to
keep doing it so
you know
ah
Supreme Omega I'm gonna wrap this up
soon
thoughts on Ennis are your criticisms
dislike of the superhero genre what are
the pros and cons of his writing in your
opinion the short version of my issues
with garthennis is he is not untalented
but he's about 70 as clever as he thinks
he is and that Gap catches up with him
anytime I read him for an extended time
I think the best work he's done was on
The Punisher not all of his Punisher
work I like welcome back Frank and I
like Punisher born and I think those are
very well done I liked the first two
volumes maybe of preacher but then that
30 Gap uh really sorry to eat away at my
enjoyment
he's not quite as bad as Mark Millar as
far as uh the sort of edge lordiness
but it's there so
he
when he is properly focused
when he is
not going off on a edgelord tangent or
um disappearing up his own ass
he is very good at writing very bad
people
but he just generally doesn't uh doesn't
click well for me my bottom surgery days
have been getting totally screwed up by
my state legislature oh God Louise I'm
so sorry thankfully I'm getting closer
every day and hopefully pass anything
that would cancel again
fingers crossed
fingers crossed I I am
very grateful that I don't have
um dysphoria in a way that I
feel it necessary to get bottom surgery
at this point in my life but I I always
hope for the best for anyone who is
going to do that
and I hope for it to go smoothly and for
a good outcome and that you're happy
with the results
thank you for the reminder Carowinds so
yes
um stuff coming up
uh
uh tomorrow
the uh
take two Doctor Who review on Legend of
the sea Devils will be up
Saturday if things go as planned there
might be a shift we'll see
um Saturday is currently planned to be a
video about
um
excuse me about Diablo the Diablo video
game franchise talked about why it used
to be great that is what is planned for
uh Saturday and uh if that plan doesn't
change then the uh build up on Twitch
will be playing more of Diablo 3 on
Wednesday and Friday and I think that's
everything coming up
you know links in the description for
most of the other stuff that I do not
everything is linked uh there you can go
to x and see my um
collect the link in my bio there to get
a more complete list
line the teacher has on the wall
if you don't teach a mate you can't have
any pudding how can you have any pudding
if you don't teach at meat
[Laughter]
because that one's not even in the movie
that was only on the album
still on the sticks of my head though
anyways
thank you very much for joining me uh I
hope that you have had fun I did
actually you know what I should finish
this
go
have a good one folks and please
remember
that you are beautiful
you're a valid
you are loved
because